Now you can learn about the basics of analyzing algorithms, and we introduced three simplifications
that make our life going forward much easier.
The first one was the RAM model so that we can analyze algorithms
without actually having to implement them.
The second one was the concept of worst-case running time
so only having to consider the worst possible inputs and not the best ones, not the average ones,
such as really the bad ones, and finally, we introduced big O notation or Landau notation
to be able to ignore all unnecessary details in the algorithm analysis.
Let's go back to the example from before when we tried to count the number of times
that the sequence a b appears in the string of length n using this algorithm down here.
And as you remember from the quiz, this was actually quite painful
because we had to figure out what is the wort-case input,
and we noticed that this is actually not easy to figure out and even if you have this figured out.
There is a lot of detailed counting that you need to do, and there are details you need to take care of
such as how often is this line here actually executed and so on.
So now that we have big O notation available, our task is much easier
because we can just make two observations and will be able to state the running time.
So the first observation you can make is that the algorithm will actually go through the string
one by one by one, and since it always just looks at a single character and the next character,
the algorithm will look at each character and again put string at most twice.
And the second thing to notice is that each time the algorithm does consider a character
so it starts out to zero, one, two, three and so on, it will perform a constant number of operations.
So if it finds an a, it will do either one or two additional operations,
and if it does not find an a, it will do zero additional operations.
So for each character in the input string, a constant number of steps is performed
and this is exactly advantage here because with big O notation, we can ignore constant.
So overall, this means that if you have an input of length n, the algorithm will perform
a number of steps that some constant times n plus some constant for all the rest of the operations,
but using big O notation, we already know that this is O of n.
So we do not need to care anymore about the detailed number of times this here is executed.
We do not need to care about the detail such as how often this line here is executed.
We can just say that the running time of this algorithm is O of n,
which would also be referred to as a liner algorithm.